the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
[Music]
hello everyone and Welcome to our live
broadcast of the summer chess Classics
I'm Yasser along with Vega wow five
rounds just like that right it's going
so fast incredible and great action
thank you so much for joining us and
let's just jump right into it tell us
about the standings let's start with a
little bit standing is for group a
Benjamin book
I
know holy smokes no he's dying for force
with pranoff and Nichols after insane
game yesterday and uh nothing else to
say yeah
wow a real stunner uh tell us about the
standings for Group B after five rounds
for Group B Andrew Hong is leading the
tournament with four points only half a
point behind Samuel lamasa La Masa then
armaan and Akshay Chandra time for
second wow that's a chasing impact
it sure is tell as we take a look at the
playing haul they're very nice
chest uh Plaza that's exactly and uh
tell us about the tournaments formats
for the two events so two 10 player
round robin tournament with 90 minutes
for the first 40 mils 30 minutes for the
rest of the game and 30 second increment
throughout the game I love the schedule
it's so simple
so today is round six and we have three
more rounds left and we're gonna have
playoffs if it's accessory and as our
producer mentioned during the spring
summer spring classic not semester
we had five based
wow well in case we have a five-way tie
the playoffs going to be played on the
same day as the last round exciting uh
tell us about the pairings and let's
start with the group a for group a as
always we have great pairings with great
players but our key matchup for today's
book versus Ilion nishnik book is the is
the leader of the tournament one of the
leaders of the tournament and Ilya is
just one point behind him yes his chance
to catch up yeah but if you look at the
line scores between them uh Benjamin has
been on a roller coaster ride with
victories and a defeat whereas Illy as
this bit
oh draws let's just jump into the game
and I have to tell you I hated Black's
position as we come on the air so what
happened is this is a sloth defense
exchange slav defense and everything has
gone wrong for black in the first place
kings in the middle of the board he lost
his rights to castles in the second
place the fight for the b-file favors
white because white is is going to be
the first to get a rook to the B file we
got to this position and as we were
coming on air we didn't understand it uh
Pagan because we just thought the
positions absolutely gone like gone gone
gone and the simplest move for Benjamin
to win the game was Queen D6 the ideas
as straightforward as it looks you want
to play Rook B2 and in case of Rook to
d8 Queen to E5
don't forget you can't Castle we're
talking about the position earlier and
Yasser didn't show me that King already
moved to D7 and I tried to Castle the
earth I said no no no that's not how it
works began and we think that that would
have been a winner instead he played
Queen before Rook d8 maybe on a good day
black could ever play F6 King F7 in one
turn he might have chances to resist but
still in this position I really like
Benjamin's winning chances tell us about
the pairings for the B group absolutely
big or they are having a close
tournament we have a lot of great
matchups but the key matchup for today
is absolutely it's a bit Chandra versus
Hong absolutely uh Andrea is just
leading the tournaments with only half a
point so if akshat is able to win this
game he's swiveling okay yeah he's
training places absolutely absolutely
it's going to be a great result for
rakshat and he is trying to do so let's
uh jump into the game and here we have
the situation this and you can see the
players on your screen yeah this
position actually comes from a Petrov a
Russian defense if the pawn were on D5 I
would say oh we're in one of those
tarash frenches where you've played
Knight D2 and and so on uh normally
speaking in a tarash defense
black doesn't have such nice development
the queen on H5 The Rook on C8 this
Knight would always already be on F3
this Rook would be on E1 the other Rook
would be on D1 and white would have a
slight advantage in this case I really
don't think that white has much to cheer
himself over now
although I must say I don't like the
last few moves of
that is a very strange decision if I was
in black shoes I want to play 94.
absolutely but what's 65 and
yeah I would be playing D5 at night E4
he played Rook C5 okay Knight A3 uh he
didn't want to step in the way of this
or this so there's a trick right I mean
this is a little bit embarrassing
oops don't want to go there so he played
93. tricks right we used to the there
was Cocoa Puffs It was a commercial in
the United States about a breakfast
cereal and you know oh was it cocoa Paso
kids love tricks tricks excuse me it was
the cereal tricks well it's like tricks
wait
yeah yeah it still exists I love those
really okay man I was all about that
Sugar Rush uh Bishop B3 D5 Knight B5 no
White's beginning to get a little smidge
of something I don't know if Knight
comes to D4 black doesn't have anything
yeah well imagine we we kicked the queen
right
and you've got to maintain and imagine
we dropped the knight in so hello uh do
something we drop back with a bishop and
let's do something let's have something
exactly yeah and that that's the point I
guess strategically your position is
good like as white but like tactically
are you on time or not exactly maybe I'm
gonna have to allow the loss of the two
Bishops just once again 94 Bishop Knight
and 94 maybe I don't have the time to
move my Bishop maybe it's time to then I
can take on Play Bishop E4 and my
yeah oh I gotta get rid of that no way
I'm not letting that Bishop Lord over
the position
um I would say that
white is a little bit on the back foot
here I I like the I like the dark Square
Bishop in the position even though they
have a compensation for sure absolutely
the players are fighting hard absolutely
absolutely what are they fighting for
we have prizes baby yeah we have prizes
they are great for the a group first
price is six thousand dollars second
prize is four thousand thousand dollars
and third prizes three thousand dollars
and rest of the tournament Players are
are also gonna get some prizes right and
the total price fund of the tournament
is twenty two thousand dollars nice and
tell us about the prize fund for Group D
Group B first prize is 4 000 second
prizes two and a half thousand dollars
and third prize is two thousand dollars
and from the fourth to the 10th we have
prizes as well and then total price fund
of the tournament is fourteen thousand
dollars nice uh turning once again to
our Marquee matchup uh Benjamin and I
I'm sad to say I think that Benjamin's
got you know sometimes a very strange
thing happened you get on the wrong
track you just have this idea that you
should be doing this and it's the wrong
idea I think in Benjamin's mind Ben is
thinking that I gotta stop him from
castling
there's no
no it absolutely happened I kid you not
there was a wonderful game of Ben Larson
bent Larson is on the black side of an
open Sicilian there was a bishop B5
check and a king takes D7
takes D7 later bent moved his King back
to E8 and it was a candidate from a
Yugoslavian Grandmaster I remember his
name in just a moment
thereafter was playing to prevent Ben
from castling the king had already got a
d78 he played a move like Queen A3 to
stop castles when castles was no longer
a threat and at least lost a temper the
bishop on D6 is frankly just badly
placed it's not I think he's trying to
trick his opponent to be honest he's
playing Bishop D6 the idea is to take on
day three
I apologize you're right he did and then
his idea if it was mimo I would take on
D3 and just play Queen B7 gotcha that is
his intention
okay he does remember the tricks tricks
are for kids and so if he goes back
I cannot believe he's trying to repeat
the move no no I mean why it is uh
definitely definitely for Choice maybe
he just wants to play Bishop C5 and any
time Rook D3 is coming no he's repeating
uh
are we serious here yeah I mean I I just
maybe there's nothing
well maybe he doesn't know that
um
he doesn't know what to do that F6 is
coming King F7 probably he's thinking he
doesn't have anything he doesn't have
enough to play
the funny part is if you're black and I
gave you two moves yeah and your two
moves were F6 and King F7 I'm not sure
you've equalized yeah so it's ridiculous
not to play uh on like for example
suppose I just played a ridiculous move
E4 you're not going to play F6 you're
going to have to take take and I again
I'm just playing ridiculous moves for
just a moment to show you that you're
not even close to equalizing with your
king stuck in the center right so one
should be the one playing for the win
16 minutes maybe he's just repeating
twice so he can make it to
um yeah yeah okay yeah you know banjo
has some problems you think he's only
this tournament has been a roller
coaster
that is a big problem for example Rook
D1 Bishop C4 again if I'm just playing
E4 it it's very very clear that white
you know he could play to open the
e-file he can take he can play for Rook
B2 followed by Queen B7 white is really
enjoying himself again Rook D1 uh by the
way we already have a result if we don't
mind
you and
today around with black pieces
funny enough Hara made his sixth
consecutive draw yeah
following in three years ago yeah he's
on schedule he's
yeah right
takes on B3 now this is a a pawn
sacrifice that white players have essay
because it's one of those things that if
black
mishandles it like for example if black
just allows white to plant a knight on
C5 this bishop remains passive for
literally the rest of the game
uh why que pasa
Queen B2 I wouldn't be surprised if it's
all Theory yeah you think so it's cattle
that's true I would be looking at uh
playing Knight E4 Knight C5 followed by
E4 I want to play E4 I don't necessarily
want the pawn on D4 to be under attack
but if I plan a night on C5 it's like
planning my flag on this beautiful
Outpost he played Queen B2 okay well
that's another way of getting to a C5
but maybe this is given oh maybe it
gives you just more because Queen B2
B2 protecting D4 and at the same time
Knight's still coming to C5 but you're
not like uh you're not taking away your
E4 idea okay so if I go Knight C4
94 pardon me and do something like this
I'm going to play E4 and then I can
decide if I want to put my queen on B2
the Pawn's not under attack or maybe E3
or maybe C3 uh I'm just saying that for
me it just kind of feels like that's a
loss of a lost Tempo we'll see uh we do
get to this position
and uh Mishra
hacked everything off the board
oops and we got a major Visa
and there you go okay not a game of the
ages more or less a very safe tepid draw
let's go to the game of darouche and
also before we jump into this game we
have another result good news
Patrol not finally landerman has been on
Wow a spin cycle uh where he just it all
went wrong I mean he's a former champion
of one of these Classic Events and he's
an incredibly strong player he's just
not having a good tournament performance
uh let's jump to the game of darus and
John Burke when I see this type of
structure it does remind him me forcibly
of a grunfeld and I think that's what it
came on yep there you go it was a
grunfeld and H4 okay this is the latest
and greatest in tournament Theory H4 uh
lately this age foremost in grunfeld
they're very trendy I would say yes
everyone is playing Everybody Plays this
Castle was out Castle just play H4 right
but it does
well and John said show me uh I'm from
Missouri
show me what you got yeah exactly show
me what you got and yeah
okay uh you you captured my H Pawn the H
file is open let me try to utilize it
whoa darish is very ambitious I would
say G4 okay uh I'm still not quite sure
why G4 was I think it would be better to
prepare but probably it's against F5 too
because black Was preparing at five
actually you think so I will be I with
just a second let's go back
uh one of the things
yeah I would be very very very reluctant
like any time you get this position I'd
be very very reluctant thank you for
anything that opens up the king side I
feel you're doing white the biggest
favor right in the world so I don't know
maybe
he's loading maybe H5
five well and again that that's one of
those beautiful beautiful moves that I
would be so so so very happy to see
because they're just too happy oh by the
way I'm I'm a pond Grabber I know I'm
grabbing it so if you're if I
yeah if I'm the one sacrificing pawns
you know uh there must be something
something is not yes or wait maybe I can
take on F3 it's not that easy
why
why the bishop yeah I'm not gonna give
you everything yeah everything that I
want uh it just feels like okay uh White
is is having too much fun let's just
leave it at that but the movies anymore
no but the move G4 I don't excuse me
I don't understand how that helps whites
attack I'm not going to play G5
I'm not really afraid I'm just trying to
understand what he was afraid of why he
decided to play a G4 because otherwise
it doesn't make sense right precisely
King on F2 and then you're playing G4
why like yeah I don't get it G4 Rook
dude I remember cartoonize advice
forever right
uh rugby one uh I don't like this move
either
um it feels like he's just jumping
around he's not like following any ideas
he did yeah he planned he doesn't have
any plan to follow and that's usually a
very very bad sign by the way I don't
think that the queen is well placed on
B5 so when I play a move like Rook B1 I
really think I'm doing myself a
disservice and I'm helping my opponent
my I'm not saying uh E8 is the greatest
uh I'm liking John's position more and
more yeah I don't like what Darius the
G4 Rook B1 I'm still confused this game
uh I must say by the way grunfels are
one of those uh openings
that I've never been completely
comfortable I would say on either side
the balances don't the imbalances don't
suit me
um but this one I find confusing I mean
right now uh to my mind I have
I have two things if I'm in black shoes
what's going on what am I thinking what
is Black's problem Black's problem is
that the dynamic possibilities on the
king side re forces him to consider the
fact that he may come under attack I
don't know if Knight F5 I don't know if
Rook H3 Rook be one of the issues but
white has the potential of attack
Point number one point number two this
night on A5 sucks bad put the Knight on
D6 put the Knight on C5 maybe I can go
to D3 secondly this whenever I'm under
attack I want to trade pieces so I'd be
starting Bishop C6
next thing I'm thinking I need to bring
my knight back into civilization
civilization to my way of thinking is
the D6 or C5 squares John is thinking
that he needs to stop white from
attacking and he wants to take he wants
to give back upon to get the initiative
himself in this case he sacrifices the
pawn so he can bring his Knight to the
Sea Four Square it feels like he has the
same understanding like similar
understanding as you are about the
position but he took different approach
a very different approach indeed you
must just keep the pawn still I love it
I love how you explained why because
this is great all right get ready get
rid of the life Square Bishop now having
said all of that
um the defects in White's position are
beginning to appear the defects the King
on F2 uh well not beautiful let's put it
that way not a thing of beauty and that
pin and give me the A2 pawn and I think
we've caught up with the players let me
just refresh the board sorry this will
just take me a quick second Queen A4 I
like Black's position absolutely
uh 30 minutes for and eight minutes
uh we have some time travel addicts in
the tournament not that
you know the 30-second increment really
stops you from being a complete addict
you know like down to two seconds and
play Four moves in two seconds can you
do it but nonetheless uh we have seen
darush at multiple times in the
tournament
playing on increment only yeah
we have a position how would you
evaluate you you'd like uh white or
black box positions me three me three
even I like their sacrifice like Pawn
sacrifice oh you do okay even though I
like your idea more Bishop c69 yeah uh
by the way I don't have the Paul I like
the other position Rook C1 uh I think
that this is a absolutely uh imperative
move uh which already indicates that
yeah you abandon your attack along the H
file like you're just not going anywhere
there it's going to take you uh forever
and a day should I take the pawn with
the uh should I
back to us uh trade Rooks although I
have an issue with trading Rooks right
A7
A7 is a little weak
like
I don't know if I've got
enough compensation well checking ideas
um I don't know this is a little bit uh
unclear for me but I do think Rook C1 is
imperative let's continue our our uh
walk around the playing Hall oh as usual
pranav has totally missed it yes again
and also wanting to notice today two
Indians are playing each other yes yes
versus romnak
um I noticed uh we call this the
Brotherhood pairings in the Pacific
Northwest you know what we would all do
is we get on the car drive downs from
Seattle doesn't matter we go to Idaho we
go to Montana we'd go to California
thank you all good things come from
Seattle remember that exactly
and we get in the car 24 hours whatever
and we'd have a Brotherhood pairing it's
like the same guys from the Seattle
chess club play each other in Montana
that's the worst I know I know and here
are these two players coming from India
but I'm not sure how
friendly they are and because their age
is so close 16 17 most probably great
Rivals they compete in almost in every
tournament right and I was just going to
say that I I noticed in the World Cup
big shout out to the World Cup
organizers as well as the uh feed eight
there that looks like a wonderful
marvelous event and I've been following
it uh congratulations to the players who
just made it through this elimination
round but I noticed that Aryan tari of
Norway played against uh Magnus Carlson
I mean these are like two guys from
Maslow they know each other they're on
teammates they're great teammates play
each other Brotherhood parent not a lot
of fun uh let's jump back into the game
of Prana for a moment because this is
actually kind of a fun position
literally we have a board full of pieces
all the pieces are still on the board
with only a single pair of a pawns being
traded meaning the a-files open
um your quick
and knee-jerk thoughts about the the
position how do you how do you like it
how do you assess the position uh I like
White's position more it feels like
white has more space and then the wedge
the central wedge
like King side as well right maybe they
have sabotage
attack but sometimes
yes so far he would he would do
something H4 H5 work for at some point
try to open up the position and I like
D5 Pawn it's controlling the ninth so
far okay even though uh black has good
age on uh on the queen side okay but I
don't know how they can use it yet most
probably the only uh plan here to just
attack on C3 Rook B2 and slowly try to
put like D3 or Knight B3 but for now
they have
exactly a trick right yep okay so you
have a problem to solve yeah I
definitely do I like what you're saying
I mean first of all uh from I think the
positions dynamically balanced I'm not a
I like the space as well but I do see
that black is actually made more inroads
on the queen side that I will than king
size yeah that I would like so for
example after the move Bishop B5 the uh
black has doubled as Rooks on the open B
file now it's not like I can illegally
play the move Rook B2 but what I do want
to do is let's let's make a bad move and
trust me this is a bad move uh what I do
want to do is just basically win the two
Bishops and more or less that on is
really really so you're probably going
to play I don't care uh instead of page
four rookie C5 is an option
right if I play rookie 2 Knight B3 I can
essentially step away from the fork
right uh if I take on C5 are you a fan
I'm not a big fan of that but like
what about my nights that's the question
too right yeah unite well your night is
going to more or less have to go to E3
this night is more or less on a perfect
uh blockading Square uh I tell you I see
a dog on C3 and
wow I don't like Queen City dream wow
well I mean now you've left pardon me I
want to say that white has left himself
with a permanent weakness that black is
he's got this Arsenal uh you know after
shooting seven immediately I'm attacking
him
right exactly it doesn't seem like right
I'm going I'm going to have to play Rook
A2 here and I'm not a fan I think that
uh things could easily easily go wrong
here if I'm in the white side so give me
the bishop give me the pawn and if you
don't don't think for a moment I'm
sacrificing a pawn no no no no no no no
no no no I I don't do these things uh I
make what are called sham sacrifices do
you know what the word sham sacrifice
comes from it comes from the art of
attack the idea is
it's fake I'm not sacrificing upon
because I'm winning it right back it's a
fake it's a foo foo a sham it's a sham I
it's it's it's a shame so I don't like
what pranoff did we'll keep an eye on
this game before we leave this uh
um
tournament I just want to say before we
go to Group B I want to look again at
the game between Ilya and Benjamin
Benjamin indeed didn't agree on on
Charles he's well I I think the game is
just lost completely lost we talked
about this and you have very very
important Insight that should be
hardwired into everybody and that
Insight is when we have Bishops of
opposite color in the middle game
the player who's attacking has a big
Advantage absolutely because you can't
match me on the dark swears I have a
dark I can't match you on the light
squares but who is Ever attacking is
literally a piece up Bishops about the
cell colors are great in the end game if
you're defending and you're trying to
make a draw
chances of a fortress very very good in
this case I see
Rex King on G6 guess who's attacking
exactly White's on the initiative and
also why can't play Queen E7 is the idea
would be seven and if you play that
would win yeah that would win Queen E7 I
have to play rookie eight and so Queen I
just need to be more tricky Queen to
seven the queen D7 would force you
that's the queen yeah
exactly it's not that easy but if white
manages to put Queen seven some pressure
yeah then it's it feels like it's going
to collapse correct maybe a rook D1 is
the correct move so after Queen j7 uh
black cannot play
Queen C8 and then because of the bad
placement of the black's King you should
cannot actually return to F5 as well
right so my approach to this position
just to break it down for everybody is
whenever we trade whatever we're trading
we're trading upon we're trading a
bishop we're trading at night I imagine
myself at a market I go to the farmer's
market there's a guy a gal it doesn't
matter selling bread vegetables whatever
and we're going to make trade we're here
to do business so whenever I trade I'm
trying to weigh who got the better deal
did I get the best did you get the
better who got the better deal usually
somebody gets a better deal it's not
always a an even even trait whenever I'm
attacking I really want to retain the
Queens so if I was white I would reject
the move Queen D7 because of Queen C8
even though I get a rook to be set you
know I get a rook on the seventh rank
yay
the queen trade benefits black so if I'm
in White Shoes I'm definitely playing
the move Queen C7 why just like you said
I want to play Rook B7
but I don't want to trade queens and the
move Queen C7 has a double threat I can
go Queen G3 check I get to I can go
Queen to D6 I can tickle these pawns I
love your Rook D12 by the way the only
thing a little bit uh concerning to me
is that after a move like Rook D1 the
queen trade
I have to analyze that and then the
other things
right the other thing I have to think
about is rupee now Queen trade okay oh I
probably should play the other Rook what
am I doing apologies C7 I believe yeah
that's that is
yeah it's it feels wrong exactly to keep
the Queens on the board to and then
still controlling B8 square and New York
right
a lot of threats Queen of the six by the
way Queen C8
well how about that uh Benjamin said I
will go into an ending I want to win
upon but but he wants to win spawn true
but let's try to keep the ability
I know it's like okay I went upon yay
for me how are you going
to question each E8 for example okay you
don't have anything to attack wow like
yeah 64. right it should be five
uh yeah it seems like it's my end well
this is where the Bishops of opposite
colors the benefit of the Bishops of
obviously color is the endings are more
uh difficult and uh by the way did we no
that is the Mishra game I'm sorry uh
let's go around the horn and I tell you
one of the harshest things is when
you've had a bad result like an uh
really unfair result like happened to
sassy yesterday he lost against Benjamin
to come back the very next day with that
same determination it's absolutely oh
it's it's really really hard even you
could see how Benjamin was playing right
he didn't have any when he lost a bad
yeah at some point he bounced back right
Queen E3 uh by the way I find the move
G4 intolerable I just
uh you're controlling good squares and
immediately you're relating
wow uh I love this idea we we have the
the term cocoon so the idea is to is to
imagine your king in this incredibly
beautiful safe cocoon and I was playing
in the candidates tournament my poem was
Michael Tall
really it's a very nice game probably
one of my best games in fact and I had
queen and a bishop against Queen and
Bishop Bishops of opposite color but I
put my king on H2 where my king was
cocooned and Tall had no chat
right you know it's acting awesome at
least for for a mission
and
you're right yeah yeah I had a really
nice score like four and a half out of
five against uh Michael uh it's not nice
to win all the games you know
the king H2 so I'm thinking you know
let's get in this let's uh you know the
challenge I I okay G4 what can I say G4
just I don't like this way of play yes
but let's see what happens oh he gave up
the two Bishops no
uh I I think that uh Saucy is not
playing well here I think he's just
well yeah but okay he's trying to Simply
simple sure right you've you've uh one
upon
two Bishops and this bishop
um how do you say it blocks the D father
so so actually there are three open
files there's but you're not really
using the this bishop blocks the D file
it controls the f file and essentially
with the move C5 not only do you get
your Pawn out of pre but you're ready to
play C4 anchoring the bishop but the
thing is that the lights position is
great too probably
and then
ah do you think so I was
we're gonna have another bit what is
this Bishops of opposite color today I
mean did somebody get a memo I didn't
get the memo Bishops of opposite colors
and a number of the games uh could
appear in this one as well uh but I
think that um Also let's jump into the
big group yes
a result there okay there is a big
Corpus pass today Justin won against
elshon then draw as well okay you were
telling us that uh Alex Linderman who as
we've seen has really been having a a
difficult tournament up against one of
the tournament uh semione is tied for
first is he not yes yes it came on uh
not Thai for first time for second time
for a second I apologize because he's
behind Andrew only half a point uh
Queen's Gambit accepted by the way just
four versus four two verses
because there are a number of books it's
it's actually very funny because I
started training myself
uh to study on structures and in
particular the bond structure I studied
deeply was isolated queen palms because
in isolated green ponds they come from
so many openings you can go from a
French Queen's Gambit King all kinds of
openings can lead to isolated Queen pond
so then I started studying structures
more and more and four versus four two
versus two was a structure that I really
studied and I felt that um
my understanding of those uh Pawn
structures really led me to become a
pretty strong pretty decent player so
you have a great time hey there you go
[Laughter]
okay uh first indication black is pretty
happy he's got his Rook on the seventh
rank before white has so
pause pause
uh no me gusta What was that why don't I
play B5
take on the E6
ah I was kind of hoping you might do
that I guess you I guess you can just go
for the full yeah and then just be
passive yeah yeah it's like it'll be
enough for me I agree wholeheartedly
apologies uh wholeheartedly okay so he's
threatening uh background mate you make
lift
and this is how the players reached the
draw very quickly
all right and then Justin Justin versus
elshon also uh drawn uh BOGO Indian did
you do you play the nimzo Indian BOGO
Indian complexes
black I tried say five couple of times
you played A5 so my main move was
Queenie said that one awesome I like
them I do and some people some people
even have played C7 C5 which is a really
confounding move because you know you're
giving up interesting yeah you give up
your ability to hit the center but A5
A5 is a kind of a nice move because it
it offers a trade but on my terms I'll
get the half open a file a2a3 and when
when I'm white and I get to include the
move A3 you get to play the move A5 I
like the inclusion for white
the reason I feel like it because I
would prefer to have my Pawn on A6
B5 right you remember uh
their structures people always confuse
should replay
right and then when they play A5 usually
there's a move Bishop B5 Bishop Texas C6
just like whole must right to know
exactly what what you should do but move
my move otherwise
hard to play uh G2 G3 so the players are
whoa
Knight C6 D5 well is that sort of some
sort of preparation I I always like this
Russian expression very aggressive
[Laughter]
very aggressive yes yeah uh D5 let's go
okay and elshon kind of uh going into a
king's Indian uh formation without the
dark Square Bishop so he's saying I'm
okay by the way the move A4 very nice at
this exact moment because it means that
white can't go for B4 and C5 let's see
how this goes Queen C2 pause pause Rook
D1 not a fan not a fanboy of Rook D1
break down the position for us and I'll
and I'll share uh thereafter what I my
Approach is go ahead what do you think
White's plan is
well he played the move Rook D1 by there
indicating that we need to play on coin
side okay
so I would I would try to I I kind of
don't like my knight on F3 right so I'm
I'm thinking
to
9193 okay and then also they have a
weakness on A4 right right so and then
try to push E4 C5 or immediately maybe
C5 but uh they can play P6
yeah and usually for example after
Knight E1 I'll play C5 the idea behind
them move C5
well it's pretty simple to stop you from
playing now you have different problems
in the position right what are my new
problems
I've got problems I know I got problems
what what are the new problems uh
potential weakness on D6 true true so I
can think of taking on C6 or not but I
don't like taking it because your pieces
are starts to work okay and I can
actually play F4 F4 E4 E4 F or Knight D3
Rook now comes to
E18 so like for example Knight D3 Queen
A5 Rook ae1 Queen A6 all very very
standard stuff uh gift meet upon if your
knight moves for example then I go B5
and try to activate the bishop right
um okay my take on the position
16 pawns on the board positions closed
positions closed that's all you need to
know is it an open position so it goes
like this a closed position no pun
trades
half open position one pair of Pawns
or two pairs of Pawns have been trade
open position two pawns two pairs of
concept and trade open position close
position in a closed position it's
incumbent you absolutely have to drill
this into your mind you always have it
in your thought who has the pawn breaks
if your opponent has the pawn brakes
they have the ability to make an
initiative the ability to make threats
if you have the pawn breaks conversely
it's on your side right so what are what
kind of things exactly so in this
position it's about the pawn breaks C6
versus C5 on one side of the board
f4 on the other side of the board so my
approach to the position uh just a
second right here
is not the move Queen D2 this move is
actually useful and in the pawn breaks
imagine we could C6 yeah C takes D5 C
takes D5 open file do I want my queen on
C2 maybe not so in this position you
definitely play E4 Bishop D7 right
91 C6 it's up to you it doesn't matter
CD
yes CD CD
or if you want you could play C5 doesn't
matter Knight D3 your palm break is
going to be B5 but my palm break is
going to be F4
and I'm going to take on even
take on F6 yeah so you tricked me you
gave me the position with Queen
went back and said here we go so I don't
like Justin's approach I'm saying that
when you're in a closed position think
in terms of your prawn breaks and adjust
your pieces accordingly and in this case
if you could play E4 and F4 in one turn
illegal I totally agree with it yeah I
would rather have bang if I've got my
Pawn on F4 my knight on D3 by the way
your intuition was that the Knight on F3
is wrongly placed and you're absolutely
right the Knight on F3 is wrongly placed
Rook A5 okay this is too clever
[Laughter]
my classical understanding is being
tasered by the way 92 not bad not not
bad even after Rook A5 feels like you
want a player in 91 93 but exactly and
and I would have again just said why did
you put your knight pardon me why did
you put your Rook up
well
you don't have to ask me twice
I'm going to take your pot I with
reluctance
great reluctance am I missing something
no okay I'm gonna take it uh I love the
idea of putting a knight on D3 going E4
especially after Rook A5 you need to
consider an id1 right absolutely by the
way look at my match with Henry macking
Henry macking
flight Grandmaster from Brazil do you
know who's the youngest Grandmaster in
the world yeah
correct do you know how old he was when
he became the youngest Grandmaster in
the world
I think it was 12 plus
14 is too late yeah 12 plus say three
months doesn't matter
something like that something five I
guess okay this is like the most
ridiculous thing of all time so when I
grew up in chess Bobby Fisher had been a
grand master at 15. it was like
ridiculous that was a world record that
nobody will ever break that's what we
were sure of there was only a hundred
grand Masters in the world
and wow that's ridiculous end of story
so I became a grand master at 19 years
in 10 months 19 years or 10 months and
at the time I felt pretty good
so I looked up the records of Bobby
Fischer's the youngest yeah we get that
we get that
who was number two
Boris faskey really yeah he was they he
was the youngest Grand Master before
Bobby Fischer he was 18 years 18 years
old we just we all know about
exactly and then Judith Polgar and
others they all came and they pushed the
world record down to 12 plus whatever
Sky the third youngest was henrique
the man I just mentioned who I played
the match with in Brazil
I was the fourth youngest
at the time I was the fourth youngest
Grandmaster in the history today I'd
never because 19 years
without that 100 get out of here
they're killing each other's World
Records uh rookie five Queen A8 I mean
again we we kind of getting a little bit
off track here for black I don't know
what black is wow
Justin what are you doing you're
sacrificing a pawn
stop my beating heart I'm sorry I need
to apologize for this
what's going on uh help me you you do do
me a solid
why didn't he take the pawn
maybe the transaction is not like
transmission is not right well I'm not
sure about that so what would you do I'm
just give me a move I I mean I'm
I mean isn't Justin's plan to go 94.
I mean if I check you want to take
Bishop E4 F5 what's your plan well sure
I'm upon up what you know
[Music]
do you think don't sacrifice it Exchange
oh but you know you're upon up already
you're going to take the night so you
know it's been working for 1500 years
when ahead material trade
I mean don't sacrifice that's my problem
I always think about waiting wait is it
but he didn't play no I don't understand
let me try to understand what's going on
yeah sir thank you okay after missing
mating
I understand now
so this is uh why we don't take with a
queen no we still do the same Bingo can
we still do the same so we go like B4
right now I can yeah go ahead
so now in this case
I'm quickly
okay
well no I'm wondering do I want my queen
on A5 or C5 If I sacrifice The Exchange
uh my queen could be on A5 and one
variation on C5 in the next here we have
the two pawns but if you put on A5 then
you're not grabbing A3 Pawn most
probably this is oh oh no and in both
cases I was grabbing oh you wanted oh
you wanted this version of it yeah in
both cases I was always grabbing but
okay can I have something else here okay
[Music]
maybe maybe yeah uh I am I I remain
tasered but if you can play if you're
white and you can play C5 and it and
it's passing through three attackers the
pawn on D6 the Queen Eye okay that's a
visual Justin
oh my okay now I'm I'm confused
um
why do you play F5 when you're white
imagine you've just played F5 why did
you play F5 just um
hopefully yes
so why did you play C5 just to play it
was beautiful C6 right but C6 uh I think
he didn't know what the outer text text
Bishop is six months probably I'll
almost absolutely absolutely certain
book C5 now
Rook C5 okay I'm not sure if C5 is a
great move
after all uh excuse me I love I love my
Pawn on
um C6 oh can I play D5
no
apartment you can it's actually legal it
is legal the bishop is coming I'm not
getting anything okay should I show you
what you might have missed no you're not
positive okay
uh my thoughts anyway I'm saying when
play F5
your goal is to play
F6 when you play G5
keep push so I'm
dude uh why did you play Rook B1 okay
this game is confounding it's confusing
we we have too many questions we're
going to let the players uh
um explain themselves
and
by the way I love this night on D6 you
might think to yourself the night on D6
is horrible no no no no it's an octopus
it defends some sort of thing in the
position everything in the position and
it blocks
the Rooks the the files are all being
closed I wouldn't
be surprised if Alshon
whether rightfully or wrongfully felt
that he was actually better he's
standing in a better position at this
moment
oopsie Daisy E3 no this should be good
for
my goodness I think that this is a this
is a clear example we didn't use the
word but I think it's a very clear
example of a player whose confidence has
been shattered a bit I think elshon's
confidence he's had a poor result from
earlier games that he had
I think he's doing really well and he
should not be repeating I I think you
know you just kind of stop and look at
the position after takes takes and
whatever plan you come up with it's not
even king of seven I guess
preparing exchange yeah I mean queen B5
Queen B4 again I think White's King is a
little bit more vulnerable I like black
but okay uh again if you're not feeling
confident there are some days you come
to the round and your love uh
energy and then or your mood is not
right you know you feel like oh I don't
want to play today exactly and then in
such situations when you have a chance
to repeat you just repeat go home and
try to understand what's wrong great
story ready for a great story absolutely
okay so and then Mardel Plata Argentina
and I'm playing in a super strong
tournament just everybody just think
about you know Ben Larson Laos Portage
Anatoly karpov lab Polly guyevsky Miguel
neidorf just like the host of Legends of
Who's Who
my dream right and I'm reading this
really wonderful novel Shogun whatever
and it's about two o'clock in the
morning the grounds usually start at
three o'clock we're playing in Marta
Plata Argentina this tourist Resort on
the on the coast of Argentina it's just
absolutely gorgeous we're staying at the
really wonderful Hotel The Hermitage
Hotel two o'clock in the morning there's
a knock on the door
um
what the heck man two o'clock in the
morning there's a knock on the door
what's going on I open up the door and
there's Miguel neidor
Miguel Knight of world-class Grandmaster
he's in a suit he looks wonderful Jose
we must play I said what we must play
what are you talking about you know
we've got a tournament game in you know
uh 13 hours what are you talking about
we must play no no you don't understand
I I feel it I feel like I'm in the mood
to play chess and I'm sure
if we play chess right now this moment I
will make a brilliancy for the ages
let's go play Blitz
I said dude
you may be in a mood to play
I'm not in any kind of mood to play get
the hell out of the door go away what
are you nuts so sometimes what you were
just saying sometimes you're in the mood
and sometimes you're not in the mood but
to create that brilliancy it's like that
magical moment when you're in the right
mood
the moment is right it's two o'clock in
the morning leave me alone so you are
the reason why he didn't create the
Brilliance correct that's exactly right
and I'm very proud of myself to this
birthday
I draw in this game
uh let's just take uh uh let's see look
at the game between Armand and Luca for
just a second it was one it's the only
game we haven't seen and it's a total
mess I don't have any clue
[Laughter]
that's a beautiful uh I I've seen a lot
of uh nice patterns but that is a really
a beautiful one that you know you you
get the Royal fork and you can't save
the queen that's very unusual okay uh
we're gonna be a little bit fast my
storytelling has really cut into our I
ah
it seems like you tell me my money is
doing good here uh can I take
that's what I was calculating
and
take on
at the night night yeah
and Knight B7 is an option as well
because uh after 97 if you also Queen
takes F5 but this yeah something's
crashing too yeah something's telling me
my spidey sense is tingling here my mom
might be doing well uh actually uh after
Queen F5 I can play Queen ESA
I apologize what were you saying there
uh yeah after an idea of Five Night At
Five Night E6 Bishop E6 Rook E6
no no neither five Knight F5 96 Bishop
B6 and then Queen F5 Queen E7 is
possible queen of five Queen E7
unfortunately you're
oh
maybe I have some chances don't you
think so
tough recommending I must say the the
the that the possibility of this three
to one majority must be in White's favor
right but we had something similar and
yes yeah yeah we these Rook endings
that's another thing uh look at Rook
endings uh Rook endings oh my God it's
like cheating uh you're gonna get Rook
endings so study your Rook endings uh by
the way Andrew
as when we left it we kind of thought it
was about evenish and by the way he did
get the two Bishops
like right yes although he didn't toss
in that move Bishop F5 forcing we we
were looking at a F2 takes G3 it was
very unexpected we were like thinking
he's pushing and then boom and he's
pieced down okay uh by the way now act
shot has got the type of position that
we would expect white to have I think
Yasser what you suggested was this great
knight to E4 Bishop H4 and then as we
mentioned if he's not uh like attacking
starting to create some threats White's
position is good but yeah in fact action
has made great strides whereas Andrew
Han has played Bishop to C8 Bishop to B8
you know
there's a lot of Pleasures in chess one
pleasure Checkmate Checkmate Maybe Upon
taking your opponent's pieces is a great
pleasure right it feels good attacking
your opponent's pieces with a gain of
tempo
even yesterday having this Square such
like D4 Square yeah oh that's an outpost
occupying an outpost but for me I also
take a great pleasure when my opponent
is retreating their pieces and in this
case like you're overcoming your phone
right you're psychological please Andrew
if you want you can put your Bishop back
off the board
keep retreating I don't care uh that's
what happened I am not a fan of what
Andrew did because guess what I wasn't
fan of what he did with like a Roxy 55
yeah this is already uh oh first of all
the Bishops
are
um to quote dorsa shish kebab
you're you're you're you're going to be
scared shish kebab you're going to get
scared uh the Bishops are lined up by
the way Bishop takes D not just wins
it's just like over yeah it's so winning
you don't have to even like think about
think about it F4 why would you play F4
yeah
well no I think I personally would
probably play Bishop takes D5 myself I
think the idea of no the idea of f4 I
understand the bishop controls the
Knight you want to make sure the Knight
comes out
well no if you take on C3
I'm a pizza yeah but like you can take
on D5 I do understand your knight is
kind of not plain not there but like
what he's afraid yeah but you can play
for any time uh well now well all I can
say is I understand from akshot he's
saying I just want to rescue the night
yeah immediately or in the words of
Walter Brown immediately immediately I
rescue the night once I now you can
resign with a clear conscience if you
take on a c three and go here and here
you can resign with it yeah probably
it's great that he's still like cautious
about the position even though he's like
piss up he's like okay let's play
uh four by the way huge result for these
two players is we do see on screen that
I do believe there's egg shot yeah
Andrew comes into the with a half a
point lead now akshat is gonna grab the
first place basically yeah exactly
Andrew's looking across the board at the
score sheet says what's wrong with your
score sheet dude
he's
he's looking at the score sheet as if
it's meaningful shaking something right
that's kind of funny oh oh he complained
to our
you got to keep an up-to-date wait
what's this why everyone is checking his
scorpion exactly that is so weird how
about you do you keep a good score sheet
can you read your scores yeah absolutely
but like my handwriting is awful but I
understand that but you do because I
don't just do that I've seen people just
writing just exactly something exactly
that's for me I think especially when I
play with a great chess player sometimes
I have a chance to play with them I'm
lucky so I want to keep it that nice uh
a slow sheet of the of the game uh
Victor corcinoy he started his score
sheets very well
by move 18 you don't know what
same with pal benko his score sheets
were an absolute absolute mess so
because I played with those players and
their scoresheets were like ridiculous I
learned to stop
look I don't care about your score sheet
the only score sheet I care about is my
own so I try to keep a clear score sheet
and I like writing down the times as
well
quick question for you do you use what
we call Long algebraic or short
algebraic in other words do you write E2
E4 the long version or E4 just E4 the
short version when I text sometimes I
even forget to put text like which is X
right yes
I try to just do that or a cross sign a
plus for check CTX D5 for example and
the hashtag yeah cd5 something like that
so I strongly advise everybody
especially amateur players to use the
long algebraic why because it's a very
funny thing when you're sitting at the
board you you easily confuse a lot of
crazy things come into your mind what
are we having for dinner tonight
why did that thought come into your mind
you should be calculating this
checkmating pattern but crazy crazy
thoughts come into your mind so what
happens is when you write down a long
algebraic E2 E4
in your subconscious you're planting
this idea that your piece went from one
square to another you went Queen A1
Queen h8 and it's sort of like this
memory it reinforces the fact where did
your queen come from yeah so long
algebraic in my opinion is the preferred
the much preferred method and if you
look at some of the really really great
players long algebraic anyway uh for X
shot I don't exactly understand why the
game is continuing this is an extra
Andrews tilted he's just playing yeah
what else to do I mean
the buffet doesn't open until six
o'clock also he's known
that he know
he never he just placed at the end okay
well that's an interesting repeat I
never did that I I tipped my hat when I
thought I I sometimes I do that when I'm
myself yeah
yeah the game it's just about me exactly
uh
uh G5 when I see the move G5 it's like
my heart skips about a a beat and I say
can I occupy the F5 Square so for me
immediately immediately it would be like
you know uh
a fast twitch muscle fiber I immediately
think if I put my Bishop on F5 just
imagine this do you think in terms of
shields like a shield okay so you've got
your Shield but you have your personal
space right but these pieces the bishop
on F5 will shield and keep the king from
coming
to the queen side right there's no
there's no King to the queen side and
then when you put the bishop on F5
there's no King to the queen side so you
contain the king in a nice little Shield
so then when I put the bishop on F5 I
put the pawn on F3 my king is free to
roam
I can go anywhere I want and then
uh Brandon Brandon Jacobson we haven't
uh taking a gander where should we get
uh isolated Queen but by the way again a
kind of a uh a position that you really
should study is these isolated Queen
ponds where one player has the so-called
bad Bishop the bad Bishop is the bishop
that is on the same color as the pawn
when there's lots of pieces on the board
the bad Bishop isn't so bad be careful
uh I love having
um like you see Bishop whenever I have
D5 I selected Pond really yeah it's no
one that you can do like
like you didn't have the bishop for
example if you had black Square Bishops
somewhere and the Knight on a floor it's
immediately lost right yes okay I
understand that like the pond uh First
Impressions is I I like the the duo uh
the sorry the
the imbalance of the night versus the
bishop because there's not a if you put
a lot more pieces on the board a pair of
Rooks another pair of knights the this
bishop you know the threats of
things on the king side I have to take
seriously when you've got no pieces to
attack me with
you I'm not so worried by the way with
the move Queen H5 if it's my turn gift
meet the ball
so that's what I wanted to ask can I put
it for apparently yes yes the same
question queen of three F5 and we're up
to date with the players uh
yes whose position you like more now
you're right I mean
um
well
um if black gets to play the move d4 and
I don't I don't win material I'm not a
happy camper but here's the question
[Music]
I I do see a pesky were you were you
jumping well I check
gift me the poem
I will gift you the pawn and take
another one of yours do you want to chat
and chat or do you want to can I just
say okay can I just recognize three
yeah I'm gonna hold that position okay
but you may seriously and I think the
position is a draw look at the game
uh between Sarah one and I think it was
sorry it was a grand master it from the
Olympiad it was the game that couldn't
devour China
Northwest this was hilarious folks you
got to see this issue it's like the
funniest issue ever
so on the cover of the chess magazine
the local Northwest chess magazine shout
out to all the people who make the
Northwest chess magazine right away
was on the top was the game that
couldn't devour China
and it was a dragon and inside the
dragon was
the moves
and then you turn the page and the
dragon went throughout the entire
magazine because it was like 220 pages
220 moves so this 32-page magazine one
game it was like a ribbon the dragon
it was a draw and we had I am not joking
seriously we had like five adjournments
I I had a queen in Five Pawns versus a
queen and four pawns and we adjourned
Queen and three pawns Queen and four
pawns versus acquitted three queen of
three versus queen and two queen of two
our team captains had to show up at nine
o'clock come on
come on the Chinese team captain
uh I remember his name in just a second
the the Chinese team captain the game
had eventually been a draw yeah Queen in
three versus queen and two he got up he
had been he had been going religiously
to the plane he went he went to the
playing Hall sat in the playing all I
realized the game was over
oh my God it was really really uh really
really awesome so you tortured your
before five insurance it was the longest
game of my career really 230 moves at
220 I think it lasted six days
sorry could you ask sir hey look I be
you know in the meantime the American
team captain eloped
with the first board from the Soviet
women's team okay
during the competition the American
Elena ashlandkova she scored I am not
joking it's really look it up it's like
9 out of 11 and he ran off with the
Soviet first born
it's like I lost my teeth
man it's crazy
um X shot are we still sing or we did by
the way Bishop F3 F3 and then it's just
this is already gone and done for Andrew
but he's just absolutely King D Fork
King E3 King D4 C4 C5
then you can please sign my very nice
score sheet I don't think he's going to
do that do you know I played I am not
joking a dozen games with Gary kasparra
and every score sheet I have the
original with his handwriting except for
one the one you want correct
the one I won it's not too late he says
his team captain FM Geller the sign on
his behalf I mean you
killer signed that's true I gotta gotta
get Gary to something you got a good
deal so she got an extra score sheet
exactly extra signature now you can send
it to him and ask kindly he comes to St
Louis often so I say Gary you know it's
time yeah it's time let's go let's go uh
Brandon uh this is the position uh I did
it kind of in a flippant manner I traded
everything on D4 unless white has
something very very concrete right here
if I have to go for this whole line with
Queen A8 as we said I'm not happy
another way you could have played it and
I was a little bit surprised because
you're really an attacking player and
you went for
trades I was really surprised you you
took here I would have expected you're
kind of a naturally gifted player to go
on the attack you know like and to try
to make a draw with a Perpetual like
I'll take your Bishop yeah and probably
this is a better way I was just trying
to improve a point yeah there but I I
think black should hold even yes I I I I
think so as well just go for the pet and
my problems with 24 and
yeah
um once again I had this no this wasn't
where was that game where we had the two
nights and it was a Checkmate I think it
was it was Luca's game was it yeah it
was Lucas game they traded the night
oh it was yeah okay because
you remember Knight B21 like jump night
V2 yeah attacking the
exactly
jumps in the storm okay
um wow uh okay he's he's ready to go
check and
you can take this night but he'll take
the bishop well he in fact that was the
game so he's threatening
this fella but as long as I
absolutely
whenever whenever you're on the
defensive and you get to trade it it
doesn't matter Queens Rooks any kind of
Trades right
[Laughter]
okay there we go I'm saving the pawn and
I'm like you're fighting you're fighting
uh Lucas back in the business here I was
afraid he was going down big time like
some glorious or English as well our
screen's showing zeros yeah I hope you
didn't fly
inside the playing Hall we have a big
shout out to our production team too by
the way they're doing a very nice job at
keeping up with us showing us the
players you know also uh shout out to
the players I always joke that uh
the players they want to run to their
room they don't necessarily want to come
and join us and we use exactly right so
handcuffs handcuffs but don't use the
Ziploc plastic handcuff get the
professional steel they they'll break
If You Think You're Gonna grab them with
plastics you need the good stuff Knight
C4 you're you're a quick take would you
like to be
the initiative dynamic or are you kind
of Defending
your book is badly placed on A8 so
exactly still you want to play with
white and then Rook D1 Rook D6 is coming
Rook D1 Rook D6 yeah that initiative
that's uh I mean uh yeah I I I liked the
pawn I like the initiative yeah funny
thing I can actually go
oh
Knight E3 1994. now that's the thing the
Knight on C4 looks good but it doesn't
attack anything Knight on F4 conversely
you know you're looking towards the king
and E6 Square
yeah I like that it's too long it's
Tempe it's it's time consuming but okay
it goes to show that I don't have
anything
compensation more than enough that's
exactly what it is Brandon uh yep we've
seen this and once again I'm wow Andrew
keeps playing
boy this is
those who never admit defeat
are seldom ever defeated
they can be defeated well he's going
down into feet but he's not admitting it
in general
right uh yeah well Andrew uh let's see
what you're gonna do I'm going to switch
let's go to The Gourmet we have a result
so shukran and Nicholas Theodore it yes
right here not to and then right here
digret because we were saying Bishops of
opposite colors but right here uh draws
agreed I think for Nicholas this was
very nice you're very no no no no no no
no very nice uh black against one of the
highest rated players in the field he's
doing well in the tournament I'm still
keeping his kind of Fleet around there
yes that's what I was thinking and I'm
thinking well you'll be pleased
well
nowadays by the way I think in the old
days it was confusing nowadays I think
it's very clear that lack offered the
draw and he offered the draw with the
move rookie two and white accepted do
you think all the chess players do as
according to the rules yeah I do I think
that they're more they're better trained
than in my day so in my day you could
make a draw offer on your opponent's
time yeah while they were thinking
and they would accept and so then it was
confused well because the rule was
you're supposed to make your move and
offer a draw but we always violated it I
did not but I'm saying a lot of players
did by just offering me a draw while I
was thinking so I think today we've got
a better understanding that it was in
fact uh Nicholas who offered the draw
after the move rookie two but there are
a number of times that uh you know it's
very very confusing why the draw offered
occurred it was a great article in a in
a magazine called
not the British chess magazine so it was
a one issue so this magazine comes out
of the UK not the British chess
it was a spoon and it was like thumbs
down on the top of them there's a stamp
so you open up the magazine it was like
blunder of the year so in those days we
had the chess informant the game of the
year oh very prestigious and a thousand
bucks for the game of the year really as
well as a thousand bucks for the novelty
of the Year anyway there is the blunder
of the year
I don't know what the players received
but of course the blender of the year
went to somebody who was down under in
Australia where else of course Australia
would win
so what was the blunder of the year so
wonder of the year was a man leans
across the board and says would you like
a draw
and the other player says show me your
move first show mistakes show me your
move so the guy sacrificed a rook that
forces mate in three
the player resigned forgetting about the
draw
wonder of the year you should have taken
the drawing
it was fun fun fun uh darush
I think uh we've all made some really
great ones
um you know it's funny when we left it
uh we kind of thought that John had
returned the pawn for the dynamic of uh
having an attack
guess what
we now look at the position the current
position and it's sort of like
uh darush
Jerry turned the pawn for the Dynamics
how was
it like something right right
yeah I mean this is a this is awkward
but the last move A5 shows the
determination to
um keep the pawn
uh your take on the position I mean
you're not getting well maybe you are
are you getting out of the pin by I can
get him but still I feel like white has
enough compensation for the Palm okay
they have some play but it can like
maybe I have some ideas if you bring the
King on G6 for example King j7 Knight H5
kg6 yes maybe now I can create some
things after like I cannot do it
immediately but like E5 and queen C2 or
couldn't be wrong and if you even like
move the Rook from F7 Queen and G8 is a
idea okay so first of all so just to
give the viewers an idea of the kinds of
things we're talking about root takes
there's a check on G8 but also what uh
begum wants to try to do with the King
on G6 there's a check on that diagonal
and we could trade Rooks too we could
get a situation where maybe you're not
that happy having your King on you know
G6
things could General it's like it might
be shaky and then because of the Kings
placement I can get my get back my Pawn
which is like B6 is a weakness of 35.
yeah I always make jokes about Peter's
Fiddler and how he plays chess so Peter
Fiddler a very Dynamic players most
especially with the black pieces he
loves the groom felt defense but Peter
is happy when he sacrificed upon when
he's upon bound he's really really
really happy when he's upon up he's a
little bit nervous
but upon now so right now Peter would
say he's a little bit nervous as black
but you know it it all depends it's upon
it all depends like let's say the
current position a lot of
it depends if you're playing for a win
as white you know it's all about whether
or not you're going to get in the move
E5 I don't think you're taking too many
risks it's not like you're
you're you know your you you have a risk
of losing as you can always do this so
if you go back just a move here
I'm a little bit surprised by the move
Queen A2 if you don't mind
D5 because again I think he rejected it
because of Queen
okay and so if I go here again I'm
trying to get in the move E5 are you
sure Darris wants wants to have a draw
that's the question too I'm confused I
don't know what it depends on his
assessment of his chances and position
and what you know my judgment and
somebody else's judgment might be
totally Divergent yeah so I I'm thinking
if I'm white I really want to play E5
and if I'm black I I want to make sure
that uh
I I never probably darish wants to put
Knight H5 to make sure that King j7 King
G6 won't work and
and I have a feeling he's thinking his
position is actually better
despite being a pawn down yeah okay fair
fair by the way after the move Knight H5
I do believe Rook takes and Knight takes
F6 check is a threat that I should
uh prevent or pay attention to so
imagine I play King age eight in this
case if you do go for the pawn and I'm
not suggesting for a moment that you
want to do that we do have this one very
interesting you know are they
interesting or bad right I mean who's
you know two connected past pawns are
more dangerous I think just blocks I do
too I do too so uh
by the way is time a factor in these two
uh yeah Doris has three minutes and John
Burke has only one minute left
wow we don't say that very often because
usually darouch is the one who's behind
on the clock uh as you mentioned unique
experience
and look at the intensity look at Darwin
she's really you know he's getting in
and well that one minute also we keep
saying Queen I said Queen D5 Queen B5
but then Rook F7 is hanging actually
it's not easy by the way E5 uh on the
board
um let's try to break this one down for
ourselves so I'm imagining we're gonna
take right
imagine a play night here so I want to
fool you trick you badly
what am I doing King AJ I would oh no no
no no so it means that okay so what he
wants I know it he wants to put his
bishop and his Knight on D4 so he has
some
oh I don't know I can't play nine to
five here
but I'm hanging
hanging no night at five night at five
apologies of course you do
a knight F5 Knight takes
made in two can be proudly announced
Knight F5 my ideas to play Bishop D4
A2 is great because you don't have
couldn't E2 anymore you I mean talk
about uh I I oftentimes mention this as
uh battlefields the chess board is your
Battlefield and there are primary
squares so a primary Square for your
Rook is the seventh rank literally any
Square along the seventh rank the
seventh rank primary squares for your
Knights are like C5 all the way across
to F5 to F6 all the way across
primary Square primary Square Bishops on
the long diagonal and it's sort of like
if you can get all of those things
usually yeah it's a killer yeah well it
is usually there's no question about it
uh wow so
all of the pieces but go ahead kill me
uh just show me why I'm dead and I I
probably am
shot before
but I'm I'm trying my uh
desperately trying to attack on F5
correct
go back sorry I can go back right now
back I did my cheat way you know what I
said about the pleasures of Chess you
retreating
thank you okay go back
furthering Knight H5 which is ah so you
go night I feel like yeah my mission is
done and then let's go back and then
just put tonight at five I I just love
uh your retreat
[Laughter]
if
[Music]
yeah I just okay so if you take I take
from
tanking that's the question
what's hanging I don't know what's going
on I think this is a completely confused
position by the way did they make time
control
they just did after E5 after Queen E2
actually
so they've made
now players can take a deep knife his
time to think about it so A5 so time
control wasn't an issue there 13 minutes
that's why we got that strange zero zero
zero yeah we're waiting for for for for
black to make a move also we officially
have the result aksha to won against
Andrew
Bravo actually that was a huge result
because Andrew came into today's
competition and then we'll see him yes
okay well uh hold your hats for that one
folks
um again
we've been discussing this game of
darush and John we think that this is a
very very exciting game uh big game
um
for these uh two top players again your
quick take you like the initiative I
know I've been sitting next to you for
five six I feel the aggression
very Dynamic you you want to kill me
every I walk in the studio guys I'm
telling you I walk in the studio bacon
is like I'm gonna hunt you down today
and do you like white I like white you
like white absolutely I have no choice I
feel I have to take they were grabbing
my phone of course well yeah
unfortunately right I am grabbing your
pawns give me your pawns baby
cakes and takes and this is weird this
is where you went night at five which I
think she immediately took was the pawn
back yes this is the current position
this is the current position we feel the
queen takes E5 is obliged Knight F5 and
the dads are I'm supposed to informed
that I can even take on P6 and be greedy
too oh I understand but that was I we we
had mentioned that white is risking
nothing yeah that's the that's the good
thing about the initiative you can just
exchange it back to pawn and just make a
draw yeah
this what what we were fearful of is a
very ambitious white player playing the
move Knight F5 intending Bishop D4 we're
talking about all of these John took on
E5 as well right all of these Prime
squares now this is going to take his
time to think about it or he
buy for something tonight if
when he played the move E5 he had made
the decision yeah
here that he was going to take on B6
absolutely yes or he had made the
decision he would be playing Knight F5
absolutely I like Knight E4 this is an
option too your light Knight E4
[Music]
um
not a primary Square not bad the
question is King G7 that's that's
where I'm thinking what to do
because now we get out of this apartment
I did the arrow in the wrong way we get
out of this pin and we're attacking The
Rook it doesn't feel as crisp
and crunchy you know like really holding
holding uh but Knight F5 we're not
threatening Knight H6 but we definitely
are ambitiously thinking about Knight
takes D6 as well as Queen takes F7 in
this case that was where I I went back
with the queen
and we kind of reached this position and
I don't know did you come to a
conclusion no no yeah I'm not sure about
Bishop D4 maybe I have something
better than Bishop D4 I'm thinking Rooks
66 I know so
okay yeah I mean Rook C6 not a bad move
I just my hand could resist playing
Bishop did you feel like I'm actually
threatening Queen T5 here as well and
then you cannot move your roof Queen now
I admit I'm tied up uh we are gonna get
ready for an interview with akshat we're
gonna lose you don't go far we're gonna
pull you back in you don't go very far
and as we look at this incredibly
exciting game uh of darus and John we do
have act shot joining me in studio as uh
well the final position I must say
certainly better for white
I don't know ax shot but this final
position sure feels comfy yeah
hi welcome back into studio
um important game huge game I was
actually going to say for the standings
X shot tell us what happened
uh uh I guess I surprised him in the
opening with Bishop D3 I mean I didn't
check if that was myself oh yeah what's
Bishop D3 it's just a move to avoid like
the heavy theoretical lines with D4 at
C3 that's exactly what it is it's just a
a hope and a prayer to get a playable
position pretty much yeah
h2h3 just to yes this was still my prep
I was just following the game between
Wesley and Fabi from the singfield cup
which begs the question I mean if I know
that you want to play
Bishop G4
that's the answer thing to do exactly I
mean you know you're gonna go check I'll
go fish a V7 and I got my Bishop on G4
yeah during the game I actually started
wondering what if he goes
it's pretty funny okay uh that was not a
key position uh your Bishop on D3 is in
the way so fine now you have if you
don't mind me saying a kind of um
what I want to say ataresh French
position pretty much isolated Queen Pawn
on D5 usually yeah but black has more
development than he usually has in this
case I mean I think that's because I
just misplayed it really poorly yeah I
think at this point he's okay
right I think he's equalized right what
that was your take too yeah maybe if we
could go back there like a few
interesting lines which we apologize
we're looking at yeah no worries so like
every 84 sorry CD4 I spent a lot of time
on Queen D3
yeah because if I can induce G6 that
favors me well you're
you're kind of inducing Jesus you play
rookie eight as well and I didn't see
what to play and he really confirmed
after the game that he was gonna
probably he's gonna offer you the H Pawn
yeah it can get faded I just didn't see
anything here if I if I can't get an
attack against this King black should be
fine I don't know but you're there
you're just I'm knocking on the door but
I can't I can't get it down uh
yeah I mean you're in his business it
feels uncomfortable Queen B6 maybe Queen
B6 a bit underdeveloped as well that
true that you you are underdeveloped
um
okay and if I'm gonna have to play
Knight D2 I apologize if I'm gonna have
to play Knight D2 just do it right yeah
I'll probably grub
and
I mean for sure white has good
compensation you're there but somehow I
don't know during the game didn't seem
so clear you weren't convinced yeah I
thought I'll just play Knight takes T4
and get a slightly better position so so
as much as you wanted to play the move
Queen D3 you were afraid that he would
permit you to carry him
how interesting is that uh what you did
instead there for was Take tape Queen A5
and you felt that you had to keep your
Bishop yeah uh as opposed to Bishop E3
you thought maybe yeah the bishop on
that diagonal it's kind of annoying for
black circus and pressure very good tell
me when you felt yeah Queen after week
C5 I didn't think I was better at all
okay Queen D3 looks a bit artificial now
that I think about it yeah it's wasting
too much time maybe I should have gotten
my night out 983 or played Bishop B3
okay but still I'm not convinced that
it's it's that much for for white or for
black I kind of thought
the key moment kind of occurred here he
did not play uh
I thought the desired move was Bishop F5
Queen F1 Queen E3 was in the air as well
Queen Ethan maybe why he avoided it yeah
wow so in this particular case I'm
thinking
Knight D4 I'm not sure it changes much
not sure changes well Bishop G5 Bishop
F4 if I get that trade I'm happy
agreed I
we were begum and I we were looking at
variations not using the computer let me
emphasize so we were just we saw
variations where you get 94 Bishop H4
and you just you feel like yeah it might
get a little scared no for sure it's
it's been annoying all right none of
this happened because he did not play
Bishop F5 and at this moment
you're feeling
I mean I was happy he grabbed on G3 I
mean objectively it's completely flying
for black but then not only four it's
super super hard to play it now at least
the position is clarified a bit I can
just make moves and the even these
variations where you do get Bishops
right yeah yeah you might be the one
exactly enjoying uh life
uh tell me when you reached a position
where you felt okay now life is going
good I wasn't I mean it was really till
the end when he played Queen F4 I mean
this was the blunder yeah he was low on
time already for the last couple moves
and after rookie three it's easy to
panic in that position or or see some
ghost or what have you discard your
calculation at King G7 objectively I
think is fine for black I mean I didn't
see anything there what was your
intention I mean I was I hadn't decided
I was thinking about rookie seven but
Queen F6 I didn't see anything
so you just felt the position
the blunder was simply Queen yeah I'm
fortunate that the tactics work out for
me here and this was
um I know it's a it's not a fair
question for me to ask you but why did
he play on so long I mean I mean I I've
been in that boat before and maybe you
just yeah he's criticizing himself you
idiot
although Andrew is also a bit of a bit
of a joker he's he likes he's done this
against me I think the first time we've
played and yeah I couldn't stop laughing
I remember he just kept on playing on
and like
something like that yeah
actually this was a big victory for you
uh we've got the championship rounds
coming up what's your Ambitions as your
uh look forward I don't really care
about the first place in this tournament
I just want to win some games win some
games so today was not a must win or
anything I just wanted to take advantage
of the white pieces exactly well you
sure did that thank you so much for uh
joining us thank you good luck in uh the
championship rounds is that coming up
very very nice Victory indeed and I'm
gonna just look at the game between
Brandon for a second uh this was that
Queen rook and Knight versus queen rook
and Bishop and we felt that white had a
little something something and
kind of does uh welcome back uh begum as
we just saw a very uh well I wanted to
say
glorious blunder you know sometimes you
make a mistake yeah
sometimes you make a mistake which
induces your opponent to see the same
blind spot and it that your mistake
turns out to provoke a blunder from your
opponent but what happened today with
Andrew is he made a blunder and he could
resign it was just like oh it lost the
game on the spot we just had this move
King F7 I find that move confounding do
you understand that move King F7 because
I thought the move Queen F4 had a
purpose of threatening to play Rook C1
if I like let's say if it's my move and
I play Rook C1 here my whole idea is I
want to play Rook C7 excuse me you play
King F7
you're I I'm like dude I want to play
Rook C7 so you put your King on F7 so I
can do it right you know I mean it's
this a tag team we're working together
to beat to beat ourselves
um help me out why did he play King F7
is that move is that a movie I think he
wants to protect the bishop basically
fair and then put Rook D7
so he wants to go here and here and
maybe on a good day Queen D6 okay he
decided he needs to consolidate his
pieces most probably and then what was
the way to consolidate to protect Bishop
he cannot really go Bishop F7 right and
then Bishop D7 looks ugly basically okay
so he came up with uh King F7 98 scenes
and then after Rook C1 most probably
he's gonna play Queen D4 okay so and if
you play some which is my whole dream
the the dream scenario yeah right you
know King maybe Kim go
or King F6
a fighter
oh boy a king F6 if you dare
[Music]
gee well you know me I don't want to
trade Queens when I feel I have uh the
uh attack
by the way we're gonna switch uh myself
out or beg him
you're going out again and you get all
the breaks that's great yeah don't go
far okay and uh this game between
Brandon wow okay
um what to say I like White's uh
position but we have uh
Yeah ironic back in uh business here as
oh my You've Won
a very very important game indeed
wow and you did it with the black pieces
as well welcome back thank you I mean
people are going to talk we we we we we
have appointments exactly together at 5
20. yeah congratulations very nice
Victory what happened
uh so okay pretty standard the right rui
Lopez uh by the way uh your move order
is
a suggestion that you're willing to play
Marshall Gambit yeah Marshall is a a
part of your repertoire okay
uh I I know that uh Dr John Nunn a key
rival when I was playing he swore the
Marshall
gambitious
he was the go-to defense an anti-martial
this one featuring D3 and the game kind
of if you were to put this position in
front of me I would say oh you're
playing a brayer
yes so you've improved on
the standard brayer position uh tell me
when things kind of went in your face
pretty sure I was very happy with my
position after A5 after A5 yeah like my
plan is pretty clear I want Queen C7
Rook B8 which Rook eb8 rookie ba and
Bishop to A6 Bishop to A6 mb4 Knight C5
it's much easier to play I Feel for
black I don't know what the comp says
but I prefer black hair okay and with
the move A5 just as you've described it
you gain space and from White's point of
view
um well it really comes down to pushing
these points whether I play F4 or G4 G5
I have to do something because as you
say you're making inroads on the queen
side you're going to go Queen C7 rookie
fish Basics B4 Knight C5 and you're
basically saying to White do your worst
I think the big plus for black is is
that I have not committed at six because
now G 4 will be not so fast
so he'll have to make me push at six
which happened eventually okay
okay so you're as far as you're
concerned you have your many menu you
have your agenda what you're supposed to
do and now this is a very good move I
think yeah and so you're making an
incredibly important important I think
our audience we should really understand
this
white needs to open things up on the
king side so he wants to play G4 and
you're reluctant to play H6 because you
give your opponent a hug right but now
you've done it you did play age the
reason behind it was like if he goes
Bishop E3 okay I want to go Knight C5
concretely because of this move Knight
C5 I played at six
because I attacked the E4 Pawn
immediately exactly
and that was why he went Bishop H4
absolutely okay H6 Bishop H4 King H7
preparing G6 a kind of a yes you are
preparing G6 but you you're
I want to say you're also waving a flag
you're saying come and get my king
so he said what else I mean by the way
if he doesn't play this yeah he doesn't
have a plan right this is he he's he has
to get on this track this for me was a
crucial moment in the game he chose the
move Knight G3 and I think you're happy
to see that Retreat yeah I was kind of
calculating night at six um G5 but I
don't think anything worked that's it
tell me Bishop at six yes G5 I wanted
Knight H5
pardon me
your intention was not yeah and F6 yeah
and just F6 and now if I get my let's
say Knight to C5 Queen to F7
F4 square is very weak and I don't see
any attack going for white okay so I
don't like my knight right yeah
so so I have to uh I have to throw in
some patties as well right I should at
least try Knight C5 94 Queen F7 rookie
three
uh small ID maybe G5 ah kind of that was
like this is kind of uh I want to say
the Bell the Bell you're just the dinner
bell you have to play this uh you know I
need my king the these uh I've seen so
many games of Soviet championships where
they've done this type of thing in this
position I don't have the time to get it
all in
I mean sometimes you ride the tiger and
it okay it's you yeah but sometimes you
feel well you don't really have a choice
I didn't like the move Knight G3 and I
actually liked we saw a position
more or less where you had doubled
we saw this position we liked it for you
yeah 97 comes and like that yes attack
is very free-flowing exactly and here
you felt good yes yeah was there any
draw offers in this game
but both of you uh
fighting chefs both of you are having a
very very nice tournament
uh by the way uh we didn't know was this
a Brotherhood pairing in the sense that
you know each other very well you've
played each other before or this was
just actually a new opponent for you
actually we haven't played much in
classic cultures but we have played a
lot of Blitz Games online yes and that's
it but okay I know how he plays how he
thinks and so does he exactly all right
uh here I thought well you just have a
yeah to my way of thinking at least an
overwhelming position I think you felt
the same yeah the Bishops are dominating
dominating and uh at this point well
Rook takes everything A6 Queen D2 my
point was Rook D2 yeah yep
might be 2 rupee two yeah Rook day one
Queen F4 and it looks lost
your whole look down but dark squares
are fitted I mean it just feels oh oh oh
oh oh
I love oh sorry uh pardon me Rook takes
A6 sorry uh he played F4
yeah and this is
this is now equal material he has all
kind of weaknesses on the light squares
dark squares I just wanted to say it
just feels like a dominating position
for you
and wow
that was more of a desperation yeah yeah
but
you just won
well now beautiful
well done I mean if there's a if there's
a Hall of Fame
for brayer you know the brayer Hall of
Fame you walk in this will be framed
congratulations very nice and do uh
rounds to go uh your Ambitions are
soaring yeah three rounds two white
three rounds sorry two whites so I want
to strike as much as I can yes and we'll
see what happens lovely good luck thank
you thank you for joining us and a very
nice Victory I tell you those uh those
wins with black they sure feel good I
must say
as we'll get a quick look at the daru
versus John Burke game and I'm more than
curious after it takes he did play begum
look at this darouch did go Knight F5 he
didn't go for the bishop takes B6 and
after Queen E8
[Laughter]
now he took on the D6
and we have this current position it
feels that trade of knights was huge and
it feels like John has
weathered the storm is still still
something but it just feels like life is
good let's just take a look at the
standings shall we and let's start with
group a indeed
we still have two games remaining but so
far nickel Theodore made a draw and has
four points while Benjamin book is still
playing and he's Thai for second with
romac who just won the game and and you
guys had a great injury and Praveen has
also three and a half points nice and
let's just jump into that and pardon me
let's take a look at Group B so also two
games
had a great prom yes and then so far
he's playing great
solo lead of the tournament he defeated
uh his very important opponent let's say
Andrew Hong and now semyon lamassov and
Andrew Hong are tied for seconds and we
have couple of games through mining
absolutely now this is the standings
let's just take a look at that Marquee
matchup and now when we left it we left
it ages ago we were left it with Bishops
of opposite color and we thought
Benjamin was doing really well and guess
what Benjamin wonderful really well
and they did get into an ending where
Ilya is hanging on for dear life
but boy I gotta tell you Benjamin is
really making what for me is inroad so I
play the French defense to play the
French defense and I hated the winner
diagonal somehow that diagonal A3 to f8
just carves the French defense and it
Cleaves it into two and the the extra
Pawn Yeah the extra Pawn on C3 at the
moment's not terribly meaningful meaning
full but it's just the activity of
White's pieces that I find and terrified
G5 yeah it's like almost Nigel shorts
drawn to each exactly exactly now it's
funny that you should say about the
Nigel shorts runs to uh to age six
because everybody knows this beautiful
victory over Yan Timon yes do you know
the game Nigel short versus Alexander
belliovsky
um
so what happened to that game everybody
so everybody knows Nigel going King H2
to G3 to H4 to G5 to H6
yeah and defeating Yan Timon in
beautiful Style
and Angel also made a king room
beautiful beautiful King run against
belyaski and walked into Checkmate in
one
laughs
anyways that's my problem
everybody knows the game
again but not the game you lost I was
like wait to say checkmate
and it was actually pretty funny it was
from a Linares tournament where where
Nigel you know
and his opponent made a move and Nigel
was kind of like writing it down him
kind of looking around like where do I
move my king Checkmate in one it was
pretty hilarious sorry uh was the game
before he defeated a young Timon or
after
[Music]
it must have come afterwards because I
think he was ambitious yeah exactly
to win games exactly King G5 I think
Benjamin is winning at this point just
too many active pieces you've got G2 G4S
upon break you've got a very strong bomb
broken importance because you put the
rugby to work F2 and immediately yeah I
think uh Ilia is not saving this one it
doesn't feel like it too many moves in
though let's see yeah by the way I mean
Here Comes Here Comes an exchange
sacrifice that's Pawn number two and
then a seven point is gonna be lovely
lovely lovely indeed
and oh
in boxing we have a jab the jab is a way
of measuring your opponent and you know
trying to get a Target and in this case
it just really feels to me like
um Benjamin has been jabbing and just
you know finding the weaknesses in in
the position and by the way he's playing
in seconds again so he has to repeat it
this move Bishop B B that's that's a
dream right so you in tune so black is
not on time
what
yeah we both had the same point what uh
what are we missing something oh
King is coming here right exactly oh my
God
well just a second hold on uh
you can see is smiling thanks
one two five uh seven uh
whoa he may have
is Ilya really smart yeah he was smiling
he's like wait a second you forgot
oh Benjamin is not happening it's not
happening one of those tournaments where
you know he's turned winning positions
into lost positions lost positions into
wins as we we didn't witness it sassy uh
lost but holy smokes he was completely
winning what on Earth has he done and
also meanwhile we have a result the
dourish between John they drew their
game let's go there and just take a
quick Gander at how that game it felt
like it was very close but
by the way I really did like John's
decision right here to play Queen E8 and
it feels better than queen of six it
does and yeah and this was uh this is
where the moment where we kind of
thought when Darius decided to uh hose
the board yes and he had also two
minutes
playing right yeah okay very good that
means that Benjamin Ilya is left and we
think the game is now
gone into a draw but let's just see uh
two remaining games Brandon I well this
this game to me I I like white I think
the White's still on the attack
okay I'm not sure uh he should have
taken your advices uh here our
generation needs to apologize right
these old classics uh classic hacks like
myself
um I think uh Black's taking some
extraordinary risks here the one problem
I have is the night give me the Knight
on F4 give me the Knight on E3 give me
the night anywhere close to the king so
I desperately want to get in you know
the the knight in Attack the rook and
the queen are coordinating I just need
that extra guy you know that extra uh
what do you do as a black here to
prevent uh the threat do you go and also
the one who's taking my advisor actually
about surren because Brennan is pulling
White
I was thinking of G5 to be honest well a
lot of things happen so let's now you
updated it oh yeah I updated the game
we sorry we were
oh what
huh Rook C1 G5
oh we were looking at our analysis I
apologize if I apologize this makes it
the biggest difference in the world and
by the way Brandon
he clipped the pawn
it seems like he's winning the game too
and should be winning the game he's
eyeballing what's better than being one
pun up two
he's eyeballing the opportunity to play
Knight C8 as well seems like the only
move but exactly as well as I would be
absolutely uh
um eager I want to say to bring my king
into play King F1 King E2 King H2 King
G3 would be wonderful but I'm afraid
black might shut the door with F4 as we
prepare to go oh my God what a game
we saw a night on age seven and a night
on uh s and it was uh E6 there was going
to be this Royal Fork how did it how the
heck
did we get here by the way Rook F1
that's a that's a visually aesthetically
pleasing move I want to play Rook takes
and give me that guy an inclusive F2
sorry I want to play
and King G2 give me and white
most probably it's Valentine
most prob most likely but uh as we get
um prepared to uh bid you fun to do we
do want to say that the summer of Chess
isn't just about the chess classics
there's a lot of events coming your way
including yes
which is from September 7 to 10th and
and we have ultimate moves before we
start rapid games which is 20 plus five
okay and ultimate first everyone knows
is so much fun Bobby Fischer Fisher
random that's what it's all about 960.
so it became uh Fisher random then it
became chess 960. but now it's just 9lx
the Roman numerals for 960. and again uh
it was some of the best players in the
world and guess what they're going to be
doing trash talking for that and then
like live broadcast right commentators
being in the playing Hall that's gonna
be awesome did did you see that uh I I
get in some Jabs with uh Lavon aroni and
I got on a good Jab
I said Levon aronian Lavon was a modest
man with much to be modest about
he loved it I'm sure you will too uh
chess nine LX uh uh ultimate moves
coming up thank you so much for joining
us subscribe to our social media
channels tell your friends where you're
hanging out as bacon and I will be here
tomorrow at the same time right yeah 4
P.M Central that's the one too Central
Time not European time Central Time and
thank you so much for joining us our
congratulations to the players in that
matter thanks to the players uh for
coming and being interviewed we'll see
thank you see you tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited